autre priorité de cette conférence de la
famille la protection des enfants
lorsque ceux-ci se servent d'internet
le gouvernement demande aux fournisseurs
d'accès de proposer systématiquement et
gratuitement aux parents à des logiciels
permettant de filtrer les contenus
violents et pornographiques edouard da
costa guys and dolls
ouais c'est désormais un rituel tous les
soirs après les cours juliette
s'installe devant l'ordinateur familial
pendant une heure et demie l'adolescente
va converser avec ses amis comme elle
ils sont près d'un million et demi de
jeunes à naviguer régulièrement sur le
net afin d'éviter les mauvaises
rencontres sur ses forums de discussion
le père de la collégienne à télécharger
un logiciel de protection
petite démonstration quand juliette lab
son prénom ou une autre donnée
personnelle
voilà ce qui arrive y'a jamais personne
qui va parler parce que là on peut
entrer que nos amis sur msn et sinon il
ya déjà un copain ma soeur qui
m'envoyait un trip en au café des images
très choquant que ce type de système de
filtrage ne peut pas éliminer car ce
dispositif ne protège que les forums de
discussion d'où la vigilance des parents
il faut vraiment leur expliquer pourquoi
bon comme dans le temps - des parents me
disaient monte pas dans la voiture d'un
inconnu
ba aujourd'hui c'est pareil c'est tenait
pas à rencontrer n'importe où n'importe
qui n'importe comment par internet froid
que celle c'est mon principe c'est cet
homme l'adjudant-chef jarre l'oeuf qui a
conçu le système de filtrage utilisé par
les parents de juliette en un an près de
cent mille foyers se sont connectés sur
son site baptisé log protect et dix
mille internautes l'ont déjà téléchargée
gratuitement vie et c'est on ne
resteront pas on te montre cannelle
danger et on essaie d'éviter au maximum
et si ensuite tu apprends à éviter ce
danger par toi même
le logiciel n'est plus nécessaire à ce
moment là nous on va faire de prévention
nous avons fait notre entre travail une
enquête récente de l'institut de sondage
médiamétrie révèle qu'un parent sur
trois ayant internet chez lui ignore
l'existence de ces logiciels de contrôle
parental
pourtant ils se vendent déjà depuis cinq
ans tous les fournisseurs d'accès sont
obligés de proposer ces dispositifs à
leurs clients pour leurs représentants
us
loi ne changerait rien ils sont en
général proposé comme option pour les
parents qui le souhaitent pour les
utilisateurs qui le souhaitent
une option qui va entre 2 et 5 euros par
mois
et sur les 12 millions de foyers reliés
au net seuls 25 % d'entre eux ont d'ores
et déjà installé un logiciel de
protection
jean louis borloo